he's a busy man and really busy today
Albert Brewer mm QB dot-com NFL insider
who joins us now good morning Albert
what trade would shock you today it's
Arizona moved any of its big pieces III
just I don't think it's me worth their
while to move Larry Fitzgerald and I
think you know Larry would actually have
to ask them that to happen so I don't
that's gonna happen and the two most
valuable pieces other teams on the
roster are Patrick Peterson and they may
have actually gotten more calls on
Chandler Jones over the last few days
since then they have on Peterson and so
you know those two names have circulated
out there a little bit I would be
surprised if either of them are moved
and if they are it won't be you know
very very happy price and so yeah those
are the two biggest names I first it the
teams are making calls on and the one
that was shopping I guess them would be
either those thick names moving most
likely to be traded today's who a good
question I'm gonna go III go with
potentially to the top I call Joseph
from the Raiders you know who that the
asking price has been too high initially
it was it was a third round pick I think
that's come down
he's a former first-round pick so there
are gonna be some schemes out there that
like him because of the way they felt
about him four years ago and so he would
be a name I could see potentially moving
outside of that I you know and we go
through all the names I'm sure you've
already heard haha Quentin Dix is
available the Packers safety laQuan
Treadwell the Vikings receiver has been
out there you know the name has been
discussed here Garcon and Jimmy Ward
with the Niners there are some games
you've heard up that are being
circulated out there I don't know I know
there are teams that are looking to make
big swim I just don't know it's a match
between you know suitor and seller
what some of those big names are out
there anybody interested in Jameis
Winston is Tampa interested in moving
Jameis Winston I don't think there's any
interest in Jameis this is a unique year
in that sense there isn't really a team
out there that's up the creek at four
Nevada the quarterback position unless
that's where you consider Denver the
Giants right now and I don't think
either of those teams are out there
looking for someone like canvas I
certainly think the bus would be open to
moving Jameis maybe more so than some of
the other big names in their roster to
Xianyang other guy who's you know listed
some phone calls but I just don't think
there's a team out there right now
that's going to bring in to him giving
all the strings attached and and the
money that he's making Chuck an Albert
Breer the insider for mmq b.com trying
to figure this out of what happens and
you know we have teams even though we
don't use the word tanking in the NFL it
feels like some teams are tanking would
you say that fair assessment of are the
Giants tanking Raiders tanking who else
do you throw in there that we might use
that word the Giants and Raiders it's
fair to say to some degree they are just
in that I think they're being honest
with themselves about where their
rosters are you know part of the reason
why those the Raiders trade coil McAfee
Amari Cooper is because Jonathas think
they're going to be any good for another
couple of years and so you know he was
honest with himself without that you
know I asked the question of those guys
still gonna be around working in good
and the answer was no the giant hadn't
been honest with themselves about their
Ross which is why they draft two running
backs and overall and going and
overspend for a loss facto I think now
they are being honest with themselves
and that makes them sellers you know so
you are gonna see the implosion Norris
Jenkins and Landon Collins out there
over the next 12 hours or so night
hiding outside of those two I think one
of the things that prevents you know
stay at Tampa or in Arizona from really
you know being in that category where
you say there thank you
is that there are guys there whose jobs
are on the line you know Steve comments
a guy in Arizona who I think did a
really really good job out of the box
when he became GM about six or seven
years ago it's been a little bit of a
slump lately and so you know is he going
to be motivated to sell off theses now
since the fact that he might be fighting
for his job and the roster have to show
promise over the flat half of the season
you know the other one Tampa and you
know I think if you were looking at
Tampa rationally you say maybe baby or
seller the problem is the Jason life and
door cutter are fighting for their jobs
you know you know I think there are a
couple teams that are legitimately
stripping down and spoken and jotting
the Giants to be in that category but
there are other teams you look at you
say they're bad they should be selling
where there are GM's or coaches both
fighting for their jobs and so you know
that would make them a little less less
motivated elastically sellout pieces
again before four o'clock their news
lady on bail showing up at 401 I'd also
be 401 but I think it'll be soon
thereafter he has we're getting to the
point now where he's going to ask me so
six games or three agency you know
they're gonna have to work out some of
the details of of how his reentry to the
program is going to is going to happen
and there's going to be some awkwardness
there based on how communication
standpoint throws some of his teammates
out over the last two months you know
but I certainly think the money aside
this isn't the worst scenario for money
on bail now you know the concern for him
and missing all this the concern for him
and coming back was putting more mileage
on his body now that James Caan has
proven himself you know it stands to
reason the fist first Amin's the two of
them asked a platoon well you know at
least on paper help him Alfie I had a
free agency and so you know I think he's
walking back into a good scenario if he
can work out some of that awkwardness
with some of his teammates coaches I'll
leave you with this I already found the
Browns a new head coach who is that Mike
McCarthy you know a bad name it really
is and I mean a thing so a certain way
with the backers and they don't make the
playoffs
this is this is the point where they
made it changed last time if you
remember Ted Thompson got hired no five
he kept Mike Sherman on board for a year
and then moved on and hired Mike
McCarthy they've got a you know first
year Jim there Brian good is there now
who could do the same sort of thing
after this year and Mike McCarthy will
be the kind of hires it was sort of I
guess take the circus out of Cleveland
which is sort of what they need so that
may make sense I'll give you a name to
watch Dan okay and that's that's that's
Iowa State coach Matt Campbell just file
that I won that one away I I know we can
Riley things been out there I think
there will be interest from the Browns
in Lincoln Riley Matt Campbell who's in
Northeast Ohio native I'd be more a more
a more realistic name for him a guy
who's you know proven it is a good
program builder if he can put an NFL
ready staff together I think he could
wind up being matech in large part
because he's very very well thought of
in the scouting circle that John Dorsey
Roger what else was he up for I had a
NFL scout who told me about like he's
the next like he would be a guy this a
while ago was let me see maybe Ohio
State come on yeah
okay all right yeah yeah right because I
know his name came up that's it that's
it Albert thank you I know you have busy
day thanks for joining us for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]